kyle rittenhouse found not guilty on all
charges
the motion of the defendant is granted
the charges against the defendant on all
counts are dismissed with prejudice
prejudice and he is released from the
obligation of his bond the first charge
joseph rosenbaum second richard mcginnis
third the unknown male fourth anthony
huber and the fifth gauge gross kroitz
and i want to say something very
important
on all of these charges one of those
individuals is a good friend of the show
is a good friend of all of us here and
that's richie mcginnis they call him
richard
richie mcginnis ran into danger cal
rittenhouse was defending himself the
whole situation in my opinion is is
tragic and it shouldn't have happened
the police should have been protecting
this community it shouldn't have been a
a 17 year old going out there feeling
like he had to do this
but when it came to richie i mean we're
worried about him you know we're friends
with this guy and the whole situation is
scary but i will say this
not for one second do i believe that
kyle written out should have been found
guilty on the charge of endangering
richie mcginnis i don't know how rich he
feels you know that's his private
business and as someone we deeply care
about we are concerned for his safety
but based on what i saw that night
i think not guilty was the right was the
right charge i don't know how you guys
feel about all this stuff you know for
ritchie it's personal we've had him on
the show several times he was a witness
he rendered a joseph rosenbaum but not
guilty was the way to go
yeah i am feeling
very optimistic as a result of this
verdict because one of the few things
that has kept me sane for the past year
and a half where we're in a situation
now you have to undergo you know medical
procedures to participate in society in
some parts of this country the
government's coming closer and closer to
your door
like chaos cities burning whatever one
of the very few things that's kept me
sane is the basic concept that i can
defend my own self right like like no
matter what if i have a firearm i can
defend myself my family my dog etc
so this verdict reinforces that
americans still do have that right even
though there are many forces trying to
take it
it's scary because what was on trial so
this is the this is winning the battle
but not the war what was on trial first
and foremost was the life of kyle
rittenhouse what they don't tell you
when the media lies is that he rendered
aid to protesters he didn't go there as
an ideologue he went there and he was
like does anybody need help and he
rendered eight i think to two people and
then he got attacked the greater picture
here was our right to defend our
communities and ourselves from violent
rights and extremists and the crazy
thing is now a lot of these leftists are
saying this is the kyle rittenhouse
precedent that right wingers will be
showing up with weapons now at these
protests and it's like well hold on
there a minute i'm not a fan of this
because you know the creating conflict
but what they're really saying is if you
frame it properly is that when when
these extremists go to riot destroy and
kill people regular members of the
community might come out
and stop them is that the precedent
they're talking about now i hope the
conflict doesn't stop
what happened in kenosha that night
should have never happened but i blame
the institutions first and foremost that
we're supposed to protect these
communities yes it's it's a difficult
situation i'll put it this way i think
the whole thing was a net negative if
rosenbaum stayed in jail for the
atrocities he committed kyle rittenhouse
would not have been in that position and
cal right now shouldn't have been there
and that's not an indictment on his
decisions and indictment on everything
that happened in kenosha yeah that's why
i keep saying he shouldn't have been
there but no one should have been there
and the police should have been
protecting the city and it's only a
logical conclusion to the situation that
there would be vigilante justice
occurring when the police literally are
standing down as
buildings are burning and people are
being hurt man the defense attorney was
asked after the trial finished what does
he want to do now
what does written house want to do now
and he all he had to say was he just
wants to become a nurse that's a nurse a
nurse wow i didn't know that i wanted to
be paramedic yeah yeah that was what he
was doing on the night yeah but did he
he said nurse
uh or did he say emt you could have been
either of those i think because they're
different pretty sure it was nurse if he
said nurse that means like he wants to
work in a hospital and help sick people
yeah good for him that's what he was
doing on that night yeah it was it was
and and and he had some training he
wasn't an official emt he was 17 but
it's it's remarkable uh
i'll say this there should have been a
mister out with prejudice for but i
don't know if that actually would have
solved anything
the reason i think there should have
been a mistrial with prejudice is
because uh that and the judge should
have directly addressed the drone video
that was manipulated multiple times yes
because now what i'm seeing on facebook
from a lot of people i know who are like
hard left
you've got the establishment lied to
left these are people who are like you
know written house traveled across state
lines the gun which is just not true but
then you have the like the
intelligentsia left and what they're
saying is well even though we know he
did not travel across state lines he was
in the act of committing a crime and
therefore it can't be self-defense then
when the judge dismissed the gun charge
they said well as we now know the
prosecution has proven he pointed that
weapon at people provoking them first
now the narrative has become
what i see is they're taking news
articles where it says the prosecution
played a video that they said showed
kyle rittenhouse pointing the gun at
protesters they circle it in red and
they're posting it in bold and they're
saying kyle rittenhouse was waving a gun
around threatening people and when they
tried to stop him he attacked them and
the judge said that was self-defense and
the jury let him go because it's racism
and patriarchy and whatever
if the judge said this video footage is
not real and we're throwing it out that
narrative wouldn't have happened what we
needed was a clean
honest victory that it was a bad night
all across the board for everybody it
shouldn't have happened but kyle
rittenhouse is not responsible for what
happened
right so there's a lot of uh
ramifications i mean obviously a lot was
weighing on this particular trial a lot
of people were very politically invested
on it but
even without the bigger picture uh gross
court's lawsuit looks like it's dead in
the water uh oh yeah he wanted what ten
million dollars yeah so that's that's
also another important aspect here
there's a lot of witnesses that lied on
the stand and might be facing perjury
charges there's talk about disbarring
the state prosecutors for clearly
pushing witnesses to lie on the stand
with holding statements withholding
evidence and again this wasn't a snap
decision i think this played off i mean
a lot of people were worried about this
coming up friday because of the fears of
riots the fears of civil unrest but i
think that fear was highly manipulated i
think there was a huge aspect of it that
was artificial because if the media does
one thing great it's not reporting it's
literally amping up the fear of
harassment in order to bully people to
get the outcome that they want so
another bigger thing to kind of examine
here is that the media absolutely failed
at their larger objective which which
they were harassing people in order to
push to get so that's another big aspect
here the jury took four days deliberated
and it was 12 people a jury of his peers
people who represented him and were in
his community that said not guilty on
all counts and and you know there's
people still angry there's people still
lying there's still people there's still
major media organizations saying that
this was black people that were killed
ms nbc nbc was trying to make this a
race issue in their byline talking about
how this is as an example of white
juries nbc msnbc was caught during
attempting to jury tamper yeah so crazy
so this is a huge realization of how
this harassment campaign didn't work i
don't think there's going to be as much
civil unrest as people are predicting
there to be because that that prediction
was used as a tool to get their uh
outcome it didn't work that's a big
story
exactly that threat didn't work by the
media but but let's be real
these activists are they're fair weather
activists you know i covered a lot of
these riots on the ground for years you
ask anyone of the riot squad or drew or
richie mcginnis or jorge and they'll
tell you like if it's if it's too cold
out no riots no protests if it's raining
no protests it's got to be the right
temperature for people to go out and
that's why when it comes to the this
beat when it comes to knowing the cycle
everyone's like it's summer summer means
riots but winter means nothing
granted it's a friday they wait until
friday so that means but it's like 30
degrees i think up there right 28
degrees or something right but it means
payday saturday and sunday so who knows
what will happen tomorrow i gotta say i
am i am so white-pilled i guess about
independent on-the-ground journalists
yes bro yes these people are essentially
saving the union i mean
but
even with george floyd
being able to see what happened i mean
that i
you know what however you feel about the
way that went just that they were there
someone some random person was there to
pull it up and record it but i mean geez
these guys richie he put himself like in
the in
in the way of
he put himself that could danger yeah
big time and and the crazy thing is they
charged kyle over it when richie said on
our show something to the effect of
running towards danger and being stupid
about it it was like self-deprecating
humor he didn't mean he was an idiot but
it was like you got to be crazy to run
into danger and the defense said this
you can't blame kyle rittenhouse because
a journalist ran towards the danger it's
their job they know the risks i agree
with that yeah and richie was smart and
the most important point after kyle
rittenhouse did fire and rosenbaum in
self-defense
we have a guest we have a guest
yeah i swatted after uh richie uh after
uh um
kyle yes there you go fired in
self-defense richie didn't run from kyle
because he knew what was going on right
so again i'm i'm i'm very grateful that
richie's all right because he's a good
friend of ours and we love him um
but i don't i don't think you can condem
you know kyle for richie doing his job i
think but this shows the importance of
independent media yeah i mean if it
wasn't for independent media this trial
would look totally different the
narrative would be totally different and
the media lied every step of the way
here to absolutely absurd uh points
chris you have something to say i want
to pull something up and i want to add
to it really quickly but go ahead yeah i
just think that yeah it's a it's a bad
situation right this hasn't been a
tremendously good situation for anybody
that's been involved in this but one
thing that everyone can be reassured by
is the impact that independent media's
had yes yeah and then when you look at
independent media you compared to the
corporate media they talked about how he
state he crossed state lines with a
firearm they talked about how he was an
active shooter they talked about how he
was illegally carrying a weapon he
talked about how he was there to murder
protesters they talked about how he was
a white supremacist how he killed
innocent protesters how he fled the
crime scene how he had no right to be
there all of that after this court
proceeding is absolutely not true at all
and they are going to be facing some
significant ramifications because again
we have a legal system that protects
individuals from being lied about as
drastically we saw it with the covington
kids and and nick sandman actually came
out and said i hope kyle sues he said
this a couple days ago he says he has a
great case now with this verdict i mean
i would be shaking in the boots if i was
a prostitute apart of the horse stream
media that sold the american people
these much lies about this particular
case because all of that is being opened
up
like a can of worms and they're going to
have to face the reality that they
created with their monstrosity of lies
it's still happening it's still
happening and i want to show you a
highlight but i do want to i want to end
this segment real quick with one thought
how how where were you
when the news started coming in where
was everybody i mean this rhetorically
but for those that are watching
and what did you what were you feeling
as you waited for that verdict i want to
show you this i mentioned it in the
intro just as end of it to wrap this up
i'm wearing my smart watch this is what
it looks like
just before the verdict came in i'm
sitting here working i've got the live
stream going you can see my heart rate
at 51 beats per minute and then within
the hour they announced that there was
going to be a verdict and my heart rate
spiked to 136. i'm sitting here
adrenaline rushing watching it the
camera shook and i was like here we go
and then a few minutes later the camera
zooms out i'm like they're coming in we
have the verdict
just before when they started reading it
i was i was nervous man and you know
it's i saw this on my watch when i was
checking it and i was like i should post
this
i don't know how everybody else felt but
i was like this was my experience and
then i saw a lot of people say
dude me too sweaty palms was nervous was
shaking and a lot of people felt that
way and then it came out as a good day
for america but
winning the battle the war is not over
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time